Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters again and we're gonna start to get into what do you do?
You know, we've got a lot of information on Hashimoto so far. Maybe some new things you bleed from that
Now we want to dig into some steps to start to heal. So this is your first step and it's your really your first step is
Diet because either these are things that you can change right away. You don't have to run any expensive
Test aid. You don't have to do anything. Just start making some of these dietary changes that I'm gonna recommend
I think this will make a big difference in your life
Let's get going. So diet is our first step. So later video we're gonna get into newaceuticals lifestyle and hormone replacement
But the dietary restrictions are
The first thing we're gonna go over then we're gonna go through some different modifications some things that
Maybe you're doing wrong even if you can glean, you know, for those experts out there at Hashimoto's if you can glean some new pieces of
Data from this that could really turn your life around again with any autoimmune disease
We're trying to get you into a comfortable state of revision where you're comfortable
Where you feel good you can live your life you can exercise again
You can feel like you get your health back to whatever degree that you're comfortable with it
And that's what you want to glean from this you want to glean little hints
You don't want to try to do everything at once. You want to glean little hints from this and wow I'm gonna make that change and
Observe that change for a week or two or three weeks to see if you can
That change really made a difference if you do too many things at one time
You're not gonna really know what makes a difference and then you know if you make huge you know tons of dietary changes that you know affect the
Quality of your life in certain ways
And you might feel a lot better, but then you don't know really which of those changes
Really made the big difference. So I suggest you just take one step at a time
You make small changes you work through this the best way you can
The first thing we want to talk about is iodine. There's a lot of misunderstandings about iodine
I have probably said it before in past videos that all
Um
People with Hashimoto's or autoimmune
Her excuse me hypothyroidism issues primary hypothyroid should go on iodine. Well, that's just wrong information
There's all this new data that's coming up that iodine is actually
Can progress in autoimmune excuse me up
Primary hypothyroidism. So if you don't have TPO or thyroid goblin antibodies yet
And you start taking iodine for low thyroid. It can progress it into an autoimmune
Hashimoto's so
So this is you know, this is new to you. You're gonna digest this just a little bit
Here's some studies this one show that excessive iodine intake and let me let me define that excessive iodine intake
Is any iodine behind
Beyond dietary iodine. So if you're taking a
Multimederal with iodine you need to stop that if you're taking you know, just an iodine supplement. You need to stop that
Any iodine supplementation that's changed that terminology here is a well-established environmental factor for triggering
Thyroid autoimmunity. So you could have a primary
hypothyroid
patient so they have
elevated TSH low T3 low T4
No TPO antibodies. No thyroid goblin antibodies
So that would be considered primary hypothyroidism. This happens to start taking iodine and it can cause
Hashimoto's
Another study
Any
An iodated
Thyroidoglobulin is responsible for triggering an autoimmune process
I and I triggers an autoimmune process. Here's a little picture of a schematic to understand that
Exogenous iodine. So your your thyroid needs iodine. This is everybody's gonna look at this a goal. This doesn't make any sense
You know your thyroid needs iodine in order to make T3 and T4. Yes, it does, but it needs just a little
TD bit. It needs very little iodine in order to make T3 and T4. So exogenous iodine
Can promote oxidative stress and promote inflammatory reactions in the thyroid molecular cell. So it increases
The destruction of your
Fulicular cells. So it decreases the function of the cells
It will read that your thyroid cells will have a less ability to produce T3 and T4
And it progress. There's a progression of your destruction of the gland itself
So
oxidative stress
It does other things that can be bad to the rest of your body too, but it definitely
Can increase the destruction of the thyroid gland. Now I know there's some people that are going that you know
This doesn't make any sense for me because I started taking iodine and I actually started feeling good
Well, here's kind of another schematic that could explain why so you might fall into
Category one example one on this chart. So your head elevated TSH you had hypothyroid symptoms
You might even have not know that maybe you were tested for but maybe you had
low T3 low T4 you might even have TPO antibodies and you started taking iodine supplement
It increased the destruction
In the example that I just showed before because it increased oxidative stress to the thyroid gland and increased
Destruction of thyroid tissue
Remember I said in other videos that when you have an increased destruction of thyroid tissue
You could actually spill out more TSH
Excuse me more T3 and more T4 so with a person with elevated TSH your TSH could go back into normal
And you can actually feel like you've improved your thyroid symptoms have improved your tiredness is improved for a period of time
As greater destruction happens then you're going to have less you know production of
T3 and T4 and you're you're going to have more seed of your problems
But initially you can feel like your symptoms improve that would fall into example one
Example two is a patient that has
Normal TSH and really know thyroid symptoms so they don't even suspect that they have any issues with their thyroid
And they heard that maybe iodine supplementation is good
So they start taking iodine supplementation and
Unknowingly
Slowly have this thyroid destruction over time and then they end up with elevated TSH
And they can end up with all sorts of symptoms from tired from
Issues with their thyroid they can end up with the anxiety with insomnia with you know exhaustion with whatever
Very common situation. They didn't even quote unquote have any thyroid problems
And the increased iodine supplementation because they read that it was good for you actually caused their thyroid problem
Example number three a person with normal TSH
No thyroid symptoms start taking iodine supplementation because they heard it was good for you
They end up with that thyroid destruction through the mechanism we described they end up with depressed TSH
Increased T3 and T4 and they can end up with hyper thyroid symptoms through the mechanism that we discussed in previous videos where you get this
Increased destruction of T3 and T4 or thyroid
Cells in a spillage of T3 and T4 into the bloodstream and you end up with hyper thyroid like a grave's disease type symptoms
Then example number four normal TSH note thyroid
Symptoms and they do if they would run the tests they show positive TPO antibodies
So that would be falling into remember the categories of autoimmune disease. They would be in in
You know category one, you know, they don't have any tissue destruction. They don't have any symptoms
They just show positive antibodies
And they start taking thyroid supplementation increases thyroid destruction and now they end up with
Issues there are TPO antibodies increase to begin with then they end up with damage to the tissue
So they can move from silent autoimmunity to to stage two autoimmunity to stage three autoimmunity
Bottom line is
Nobody really should be taking iodine supplementation. So
I know there's arguments about iodine supplementation and
Protecting us against radiation and I do believe that
Some breast cancer passage should be taking iodine supplementation
But only for that period of time to get them through their breast cancer than I think iodine supplementation needs to discontinue
And if you're an if you're exposing radiation if you're exposed to radiation toxicity
That is a time to take iodine supplementation too. So it might be
Cancer patient that's doing radiation therapy
Or it could be a person that is exposed to radiation toxicity due to environmental concerns
So taking iodine while you're exposed to that can be beneficial, but not long-term basis
There's even more data out there if you're reading on here
That show that when you reduce iodine when you go on a iodine restrictive diet
You could actually reverse
Hashimoto symptoms
Would that be nice you know here you're dealing with Hashimoto and you're dealing with all these symptoms of thyroid dysfunction
And maybe you can't lose weight or you just have tiredness you can't sleep
And some of the issues you have constipation whatever your symptom pattern is or has been with Hashimoto's
Would it be nice if you could just go on a iodine restrictive diet
And you reverse a lot of your symptoms
Wow
You know there's a critical pearl for you
What an easy way to start you should have to run any tests at all
I'm just gonna go on a iodine restrictive diet
Well, what would that look like?
So I'm gonna get rid of my salt that has a iodine salt and sea salt has iodine in it too
You can just start flavoring with you know your food with garlic and certainly a lot of different herbs
Out there that you could start flavoring with stop using salt
Stay away from high salty things that would have iodine in it like fish and kimchi
Stay away from dairy, which is she probably would be staying away from business across reactive with gluten anyhow
Can foods they're gonna have salted it like fruit cocktails and all that kind of stuff can
Vegetables shouldn't be that stuff anyhow
Stay away from foods that could carry dyes and red dye in particularly
But you probably stay away from that stuff anyhow right potatoes have a lot of iodine in it
So that would might be a harder one for people
But you can eat sweet potatoes sweet so sweet potatoes are a substitute for your potatoes
Convenience foods obviously have a lot of salt in it restaurant foods and a lot of multivitamins are going to have
iodine in it so you want to stay away from those things that if just read the label
So use some other thing to salt your food with eggs why egg whites don't have any iodine in it
And you can make other substitutes and just cutting back on some of these things can make
Giant difference
Give this a try why not good or say this is a really a fairly easy
solution here, so
I would say you know go for it. This is a nice thing to look at
Another thing that people
Talk about with Hashimoto's is Guitarsons Guitarsons are a
You know, this is is an old thing. This is an island when I was back in school
If you have thyroid issues you need to stay away from foods that
Can interfere with iodine uptake in the thyroid gland. So the definition of Guitarsons are substances foods
We're talking about the disrupt the production of thyroid hormone
By interfering with iodine uptake in the thyroid gland
Well, if you just listen to the last section that I talked about iodine
You're going to realize that this food list that is recommended to stay away from is actually probably the food list that you should be eating
so
Not all these things because
you're you're gonna see that
that
That's not complete. It's not perfect, but
For instance studies that have come out that soy supplementation has no effect on thyroid
Hormones now. I'm not saying that you should be eating soy, but
That can affect other hormones your your
Estrogen and progesterone, but
So a supplementation
Does not affect thyroid hormones. It's not a
Guitarsons are not a negative effect on your thyroid
Thyroid stimulating hormone-free
Thyroxid and thyroid gland were not affected
By taking
By consuming
This study showed broccoli seed broccoli sprout beverage. So broccoli sprouts are really good for you
And can really help pull out bad estrogens
Highly recommended for anybody with any type of hormone related cancer
So for a fate is a fantastic supplement to help
reduce bad estrogens and and bad estrogens and negative estrogens
The tabletota comes to cancer also can be very anti-cancerous in itself
But it's something broccoli is something is that Guitarson that's that's that's the that number one Guitarson that
That you have heard over the years that a cat that a that a
Thyroid patient should be staying away from but in truth
It's probably one of the best foods for a thyroid person
To be eating because it does compete with iodine uptake of
The thyroid gland and that's what you want to do
You don't want excess iodine in the thyroid gland because it causes that oxidative stress and everything that we talked about
So in conclusion there are
This study talks about iodine status of thyroid function
With vegans and vegetarians because that was the issue you shouldn't be eating an vegetarian diet with your thyroid gland
But this again shows that is it's the exact opposite of what we had learned and what we what I taught years ago too
so
This one talked about this study talked about thyroid cancer and
And
Some different nutrients that would be considered Guitarsons that you should stay away from the cruciferous vegetables
That was the number one thing that you need to stay away from if you have thyroid cancer if you have any thyroid issues
You have your hypothyroid if you have Hashimoto's and the truth is just the exact opposite
We should be eating those things and one of the things that they found that it's so beneficial for is that it stimulates
Guitathione production and that's that's a key component to this
So Guitargenic foods are found to not cause goiter issues are not they're not a cause of thyroid cancer
They do not disrupt T3 and T4 they do not cause
Nor contribute to worsening of hypothyroid primary or Hashimoto's
So all that was just false information that we need to get back to understand it eating gods
The way is just the best way to go there are we're going to talk about in not in this video about a future
But there are chemical goiter. So there's there's there's
I talk about it in the in the previous modules about different
chemicals that you have to look at that can cause
An overreaction
I wouldn't say it's a sensitivity, but it stimulates an immune process with autoimmune patients
That can make an autoimmune disease worse. Well, that's still the case with
with Hashimoto's
So we do want to look at those that we could call those those have been labeled as literature chemical guitargen
So I just want you to know that that's not what we're talking about. We're talking about food goitergens
And you can still google I did that before I did this video
Oh, there are lists for food goitergens out there. There are tons of lists of food goitergens things that you should not be taking when you have thyroid issues
when you have Hashimoto's you need to just cross that out
And start consuming those foods
That might be a great next step. So if you are
Have been stayed away from broccoli and things like that and cruciferous vegetables
Why don't you make that change start eating those things that will increase glutathione levels
It will decrease oxidative stress in the thyroid
Raising glutathione can protect the thyroid against the oxidative stress
response in Hashimoto's
so
And then
What I already said it actually competes these foods compete with iodine
Especially if you're on iodine restricted diet so they will help reduce your overall iodine
They might make a giant difference that could be your answer right there to really get you to a stage where you're really feeling much better
The next thing is gluten. I've hounded on this for a good decade
At least about gluten and Hashimoto. I mean, it's just there's just no way that anybody with thyroid issues should be eating gluten
You do not even need to go run any syrex tests
Don't even bother you just gotta stay away from gluten
It's just their study after study that show that what patients with
Celiac disease one on a gluten-free diet
It helped their TSH level and you don't have to have celiac disease
Just going on a gluten-free diet is gonna make a big difference. This is something that
You know, it's gonna you know, I said you start with the iodine restrictions start with going back to eating some
What were considered goiogenic foods, but you really you really have to go on a gluten-free diet. It's just really a must
I could show you study after study, but I'm not gonna spend much time on this
This isn't overlooked one lectins. There are lectins in gluten. There is in gluten foods
There are lectins in other things too. This can be a problem
And again, you could do let's say if you've done all the three above this and you're still having issues
If you want to go to the next level is start looking at lectins
You could certainly do a food elimination diet when looking when trying to eliminate lectins
The lectins are found in legumes, dots and seeds, grains, fruits
And vegetables the most common are tomatoes potato and plant
And peppers so peppers out of the list but peppers as well
so but
Going, you know, restricting those foods can make a giant difference. Certainly doing
At a rate 3x from Syrex and at a rate 10 from Syrex will get more
specific on maybe the lectins that you're having issues with because this
I think going on a lectin-free diet is probably more disruptive and take
Keyed out some joy in life than even going on a gluten-free diet
So this is one that you may want to run some tests for. You can certainly eliminate one at a time and see if it makes a difference
But looking at this from a test perspective can help get specific for you so you're not eliminating a lot of stuff that maybe you're not reacting to
Lectins have shown to increase TH17
And interleukin-17 which is a highly inflammatory response
And then you have some cross reactivities with gluten with lectins as well
so
It crossed the lectins themselves can cross react with TPO antibodies
And cause an increase in TPO autoimmune reaction to the thyroid and thyroid site, the thyroid cell destruction
So it's something to look at. It's the next step to look at
And then the last step in diet would be to go on a full paleo autoimmune paleo diet
At an autoimmune paleo diet, there's some autoimmune paleo cookbook
Cookbook's out there that can be helpful
But that's where you're eliminating gluten, you're eliminating all grains, rice, oats, tapioca,
quinoa, millet, teff, you're eliminating all dairy, whey,
corn, soy, you're eliminating lectins and night chains
And so it's a much more restricted diet
It's difficult to follow
It takes a lot of joy out of life
And but it is the next step in really looking at
Making dietary changes and really the last step is really
doing a full
Cyrex workup
And you can do that before you get to that so you're not having to go on a full autoimmune paleo diet
If you do a full Cyrex
Workup to check protein cross-reactivity peptide tests cooked in raw foods
That's a Cyrex 10 that can be really beneficial to nowhere to go
But then you really have to do that again because you certainly can't stick to that
Nor do you need to stick to that diet forever
A lot of the food peptide antibodies to peptides
We'll clear out in after one to six months of being on a diet
Typically antibodies are never going to clear out
Dairy antibodies
Some of them may not clear out
But a lot of the other ones will clear out
Like if you have antibodies to tapioca
Let's say I'm going up on the Cyrex 10
Staying away from tapioca for three months
You could run it again and your antibodies really have gone down to zero
And you could slowly introduce those things again
We'll see that throughout clinical practice through the year
So
But step by the time take these steps
This at least looks at different cross-reactivity to different foods
Which can be molecular mimics to the thyroid gland itself
I remember food molecular mimics can stimulate antibodies
If you have antibodies to other things too
So remember going back to the rest of the course
You quite possibly don't just have one autoimmune disease going on
I mean if you have antibodies to cerebellar
Cells you may have antibodies to other neuronal cells
You may also have brain inflammation
So any inflammation that you're causing in your gut that may not
Directly be causing an issue to thyroglobulin
And
Stimulated TPO antibodies can stimulate inflammation
And the brain could cause your problems to get worse
It's important to remember that just because I have let's say
Hashimoto's does not mean that every symptom that I have is from Hashimoto's
So I can be having a symptom from
You know
From
You know brain inflammation that is completely independent from Hashimoto's
Because of the alcohol I drink and and that's not good
So we don't want to just you know, it's like when I talk with
Cancer patients is you know, oh my
I have this problem that doesn't mean that I have metastasis
We want to think that because we have this problem that every symptom that I have
Is related to that problem no matter how grave that problem would be
In the case of cancer, but
If that's just not always true
So you most the time have comorbidities
You've heard heard that term come up with the last few years
We have other things going on at the same time
And
That's understandable so we have to address those as well
Next step in dietary considerations with Hashimoto's
It's dietary modifications so the first one is micro biodeiversity
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on this, but micro biodeiversity can be
A mistake that we make when we're trying to clean up our diet
We're we're restricting our diet so much
I remember what I first this was actually what I was an intern back in the 80s
Okay
Dating myself here
I had what would come in with her daughter
And she had I can't remember but she had all sorts of health issues
And it was just a a little four year old girl or something like that at the time
All sorts of health issues
And
Would do it a full work up on her
They were a strong Italian family
And they ate
You know the same types of food on a daily basis
So this child literally grew up with a very low microbiome diversity
Because your diversity of your gut microbiome has to do with all the different kinds of foods you eat
And the lack thereof of diversity is if you've limited yourself to a very specific diet
That doesn't have that diversity
In this case this strong Italian family were eating just tomatoes
Tomato sauce at least twice a day
At a very specific diet
We'll testing her she came back
positive for food sensitivities to
Tomatoes and
And the like foods and we all we did is change her diet and her life just completely changed
And she had been everywhere met the Mayo but the every place
And it was just that simple increasing the diversity of the diet taking away food sensitivities
That literally changed her life
It was years later
Had to see this person I had gone into practice
But a different part of the city
The mom and the daughter came back she was a teenager
Because they were moving to some other state
And they wanted to come back and thank me because I changed their life
And changed this girl's life when they thought she was
They were recommending intestinal surgery
They had diagnosed her with inflammatory bowel disease
At four years old or something like that
Some crazy thing like this and they came back to thank me
It was just a very simple fix
You know it's just every all the concepts that we're talking about here
So I'll go into much more detail about this
But there's a study after study that show that dietary fiber diversity food diversity
Is microbiome diversity
Eating is many different types of foods
And different foods that you've never eaten
You know and changing
I think there's a lot of value I've spoken about
Over the years of eating in season I think that God
Created food to be in season maybe we're not supposed to be eating apples
Every single day
You know they're in 65 days
A year maybe we're only supposed to eat them
For three to six months maximum every year
Because they just go bad after that
Maybe we're not supposed to be able to eat citrus every day
We're supposed to only eat it when it's in season
Things grow in season and not that we're not supposed to preserve
Food to be able to survive
But maybe to change our diversity
Can be very helpful
Next point is sodium intake
We talked about that with iodide
But sodium and iodide always go together
Now if you're eating pig salt
Emily and salt you're thinking you're getting a better quality
Nutrient that you are because you're getting
You know more nutrients in that pig salt
And if you're taking iodized
Table salt which is horrible for you
However pig salt also has iodide in it
So if you're going to the iodide low iodide
You're eliminating pig salt
But to take away the iodide portion of this
And even take away the Hashimoto's portion of this
Sodium itself can be a major problem with all autoimmune diseases
So a high salt diet has been shown
Study after study to increase interleukin 17
So whenever interleukin 17 is a highly inflammatory cytokine
And it can stimulate autoimmune flair
Anywhere in the body
Whether you have rheumatoid arthritis
Whether you have
Shogrid's disease
Whatever you know Hashimoto's or whatever autoimmune disease you have
Sodium itself
A high salt diet can
Will increase interleukin 17
Even if you don't have an autoimmune disease
Sodium is going to increase interleukin 17
That's part of the problem that it can happen
With people that have cardiovascular issues
Why do some people on a high normal American salt diet have no increase in high blood pressure
And some people do
And it's because if you have high blood pressure due to
In a mute attack of the endothelial cells
Which I may make a whole video of cardiovascular issues that may be helpful for people
But if your cardiovascular system
Your vessels are aligned by these epithelial cells called endothelial cells
And underneath the endothelial cells you have the smooth muscle
Array and contraction of that smooth muscle array
Causes an increase in blood pressure
And it's for a purpose to shut blunt to your extremities
To run away from something
However on some people have a sense call
What used to be called a sensitivity to sodium
And that sodium causes that constriction
What it really has to do with some people have an autoimmune response
In that smooth muscle layer
Many times caused from H. Pylori
Many times caused from heavy metal toxicity
And an increase in interleukin 17
Causes a constriction of those muscles
Because it increases inflammation
And inflammatory damage causes constriction of those muscles
And increases the person's blood pressure
So it's the same thing with autoimmune destruction of the thyroid gland
So increase interleukin 17 is going to increase oxidative stress
To the thyroid gland go back to the previous slide
That we talked about that
Sorry I'm going so fast but I know we're running late on this video
And one thing is shown to block it
You see on this slide in that upper right hand corner
That red line with the bar
When you look at medical literature
And you see something like that
That means that substance that's listed to that blocks that reaction
That's potassium chloride
So K is potassium and chemistry potassium chloride
Actually blocks this reaction of sodium chloride
In its production of interleukin 17
So if you take potassium with a high salt meal
Let's say okay I'm going to go out to eat
So good to say
I you know what am I going to eat
No salt diet when I go out to eat
Good luck with that
Yet you're anything
This is going to be highly salted
Take some potassium with you
When that be an easy fix
So I'm going to stop salty in my food at home
I'm going to start using
Your garlic
I'm going to start using thyme and oregano
And I'm going to start using things
It's really good herbs
That actually can have some really great benefits
For pathogens in my body
And let me have to take supplements
Your herbs
Many people have a cabinet full of herbs
That are better supplements than supplements
That are out there
Then if you just get some potassium supplementation
Take a few potassium cabinets with your meal
It can block this sodium chloride
Production of interleukin 17
It can decrease the inflammatory process
What a simple fix
Unbelievable simple fix
This is a key piece for a lot of people
So don't ignore this
And then lastly dysglycemia
Disglycemia has to do with this bouncing of your blood sugar
We talked about it in a previous video
People with Hashimoto's
And end up with a with them
With these insulin surges
It increases all sorts of inflammatory processes in your body
It increases destruction of your thyroid gland
It's all about these insulin surges
So you're consuming a lot of carbohydrates
And starches
It causes hyperglycemia
It causes an insulin surge
And what do you see
Common scenario
It increases interleukin 17
It also increases
And Fcapabeta
Which is made in inflammatory pathway
And increases activation of a TH-17
In an autoimmune reaction
This is anywhere
This is not just thyroid issues here
Insulin surges are going to make
80 autoimmune disease worse
So
Now what you can see
We're starting to unwind this
A little bit
We got more videos
And the next step is to unwind it
A lot to go through
I know this is a long video
But I know there's a lot of information
You might have to go through it several times
But this is
This is what we're doing
We're trying to study
And to learn this stuff
And to get better at it
And to improve your life
Stay with me
No, I'm praying for you guys
We'll keep learning